les mesures de freinage s'étendent petit
à petit l'aube la nièvre et le rhône
rejoignent les 16 départements placés
précédemment en confinement par
l'exécutif
l'annnonce du ministre de la santé était
pressenti depuis plusieurs heures à
compter de ce vendredi minuit et pour
quatre semaines donc dans ces trois
départements le couvre-feu continue de
s'appliquer
de 19 heures à 6 heures les
rassemblements en extérieur ne doivent
pas dépasser six personnes les
déplacements sont autorisés de 6 heures
à 19 heures lorsque c'est dans un rayon
inférieur à 10 km sans attestation sans
limitation de durée
on vous demande d'avoir sur vous un
justificatif de domicile comme une pièce
d'identité entre 6 heures et 19 heures
si vous dépassez 10 km depuis votre
domicile mais également de 19h à 6h
cette fois ci quelle que soit la
distance vous devrez avoir une
attestation dérogatoire pas de
confinement généralisée pour l'instant
malgré des indicateurs épidémique qui ne
s'infléchit ce pas le gouvernement se
donne une dizaine de jours pour évaluer
l'efficacité des mesures en place
olivier ferrand qui explique également
qu'en raison des variants et de la
vaccination déjà avancé des seniors les
patients en réanimation sont de plus en
plus jeunes quant aux écoles elle reste
ouverte et ne seront fermées qu'en
dernier recours mais s'apprête à voir
leur protocole sanitaire une nouvelle
fois renforcé
pourquoi est-ce que nous maintenons les
écoles ouvertes la fermeture des écoles
c'est une décision de dernier recours
que nous voulons à tout prix éviter
parce que nous savons qu'elle a des
conséquences très lourdes sur le
développement des enfants et sur le
quotidien des parents nous ne nions pas
que le virus peut aussi se transmettre à
l'école puis de l'école vers les
familles c'est pourquoi avec le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
nous travaillerons à des protocoles
sanitaires renforcés en sus de ceux qui
sont déjà mises en place dans les
établissements scolaires l'éducation
fait donc toujours partie des priorités
affichées par les autorités depuis le
très strict premier confinant les écoles
n'ont plus fait l'objet d'une fermeture
généralisée